[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive time then to
see what is making the headlines with
the daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire and the columnist for the
article ali mirage welcome to both of
you as ever let's turn our attention
straight to uh the front pages
and uh the ft then taking in both big
stories of the day their headline
johnson adopts plan b to check virus as
anger festers over parties
the eye reporting that bruce johnson
rushed forward new covert restrictions
in england after an outcry of a downing
street staff joking about breaching
lockdown restrictions
pm taking the public for fools is the
metro's headline which says the prime
minister is facing growing calls to quit
over an alleged christmas party at
number 10 and then announcing plan b
the daily telegraph says boris johnson
has told millions of people to work from
home yet said they can still have office
christmas parties prompting suggestions
that the new rules were illogical
the pm announcing new covered
restrictions is also on the front page
of the guardian which also says labor
claims he's lost his moral authority as
his government is engulfed in a crisis
of credibility
and the sun has boris johnson as the
grinch on its front page with reports
he's being accused of one rule for them
one rule for us
so kevin maguire ali mirage are here ali
thank you for stepping in a short notice
as well much appreciated let's start
with you then uh to the guardian i guess
um plan b
the party scandal um both at the door of
number 10 what a day
absolutely uh anna indeed what a day and
i actually
uh was just before coming on with you
was at a dinner in the city of london
and i took a straw poll of the guests
around my table thinking that uh
this uh plan b announcement that was
made by the prime minister only a few
hours ago what really led to this and
the consensus around my dinner table
this evening
was that it was to distract attention
from the christmas party that allegedly
took place
last year on december the 18th now
this is the problem because if the prime
minister is announcing new measures
there are two issues that he faces one
is
credibility with the public
which i think is really sadly now
lacking i mean if we're all meant to be
adhering to these new rules and plan b
basically means the the advice is to
stay at home if you can from monday and
also now bringing in vaccination
passports in larger gatherings making uh
it mandatory to wear face masks uh even
beyond what we're wearing now
people are gonna think well hang on a
second it's one rule for us and it's one
rule for those uh in power and this goes
back to the dominant cummings fiasco
last year and now we have this issue and
certainly look at the prime minister's
uh advisor has resigned uh today but i
don't think that puts a line under the
story so i think credibility is one
issue with the public and the other
issue is uh that the prime minister's
got problems with his own back benches i
mean can you imagine being a tory back
venture at the moment having to be
trotted out to defend this nonsense uh
only to have your your legs cut from
beneath you when policy changes all the
time so i think he's got problems on two
fronts okay where do you want to start
which front do you want to start on
kevin
if we just stick with the guardian for a
moment uh anna
they do quite rightly point out that
he's rushed forward these proposals on
his plan b he's always
dawdled and dithered in the past and
it's it's quite clear as william rag one
of his own mps senate prime minister's
questions it's a diversionary tactic
he's brought it forward and
you could hear the concern in the voices
of chris whitney and patrick valenz the
chief medical officer in england and the
government's chief's scientific advisor
that they worry people will not follow
the new rules now because they think
it's just boris johnson trying to
distract attention from his problems
over the
over the party and there is an element
in that yet at the same time
those warnings from sage that
hospitalization from the new uh
there and the omicron could be 2 000 a
day and overwhelming overwhelm the nhs
you see why
there are there is a need for
restrictions however logical some of
them are and contradictory uh although
others just bring england really broadly
into line with scotland and and wales
the fact is the prime minister acted
politically to save his own skin after
throwing one of his advisers under the
bush because essentially he's been
found out and the foreign secretary the
police minister the health secretary the
vaccines minister all have been
wheeled out in the past week to pretend
there was no party and insist rules were
followed well if there was no party and
rules were followed why has he lost his
former uh spokesperson it's it is
completely illogical and contorted and
boris johnson is in a serious mess here
and it's it's not over and it's one of
its own making because he hasn't obeyed
rules and he's always tried to avoid
honesty and he's always trying to just
talk or
brazing his way out or lie his way out
of problems and i'm afraid for his point
of view the country's wised up which is
why there are two polls tonight finding
more than half the country you think you
should go and a sizable chunk of
conservatives are of that uh opinion too
yes and we'll come back to whether the
rules are followed and allegra stratton
in just a moment but on that issue of
the diversionary tactic i mean the ft is
another of the newspapers to conflate
the plan b and the parties issue
together sage did brief the cabinet on
tuesday ali and gave warnings about this
and the problem with the exponential
rise of a variant like this is it starts
really slowly and can lull you into a
full sense of security and you look at
the graph it pops along pops along until
about december the 23rd 24th and it goes
off like a rocket and that that's the
danger isn't it that's why you had
people like professor chris whittie
saying we need to get ahead of it
well and you also bear in mind what
happened last year around this time as
well anna when christmas effectively got
cancelled for millions of people up and
down the country that were very much
looking
forward to it so it is a it is a serious
issue however the picture is mixed it's
still too early to really understand
whether this virus is as virulent as its
previous incarnations delta uh beta and
others uh we just don't know yet and and
whilst it's true to say that certain
other countries austria being a good
example which is effectively locked down
is actually going to introduce mandatory
vaccination
as of early next year germany now also
considering doing the same and has also
locked down parts of its own country
it's certainly true to say that certain
countries are taking this very very
seriously um but look
scientific advisors have one metric and
one metric alone which is to prevent
hospitalizations and deaths that is the
sole metric which they are judged by the
government has a much broader uh issue
set of issues to deal with including
physical and mental health we know that
there is a waiting list at the moment
nhs waiting list of 5.8 million people
potentially could go up to 13 million
which would be absolutely staggering and
also rishi sonak has got a 2 trillion
pound public debt to deal with and 400
billion of borrowing on the back of the
covert pandemic and the furlough scheme
and other bounce back load schemes etc
so the government always has to look at
this in the round and balance the risks
to public health with the wider risk to
not only the economy but also physical
and mental health and it just seems to
me that this has been rushed out i look
to be fair to the prime minister he
wants to learn lessons from last time
when he locked down last year was
criticized for locking down late but it
just seems to me that it's all been
rushed out today and the one thing that
the conservative mps that i've been
speaking to over the last few weeks just
wanted was for the government to get to
christmas without any further
self-inflicted mishaps we had the whole
entire fiasco over owen patterson and
the second jobs we had the botched
announcement over hs2 we had the ongoing
issue with the migrants crossing in a
death of 27 the other week and all that
they wanted was to get to christmas
without any more self-inflicted wounds
and unfortunately um this is what we now
have this party issue going on
and now potentially on the way to
another lockdown and there's a lot of
resistance among some of the tory back
benches including the coveted recovery
group and others who feel uncomfortable
and since charles walker um who's a
leading tory backbencher said look if
the government wants to introduce new
restrictions that's all very well but it
should be purely on a voluntary basis on
the back of the fiasco over this party
that did or did not happen last december
many of the loudest voices are obviously
per se against restrictions aren't they
so that's the the difficulty here the
eye as well kevin pm's 24-hour u-turn on
coveted plan b top of their uh front
page two is a picture of a very tearful
allegra stratton uh resigning as we saw
there
over the allegations of the party which
are now being investigated by the
cabinet secretary plenty of questions
that we still don't know the answer to
who organized it who was there did it
happen what was the purpose of the
gathering uh you name it you know how
and why was it first convened if it
happened
london went into tier three on december
the 16th this is the legislative
happened two days later
and the rules specified that you must
not have a work christmas lunch or party
where that is primarily a social
activity
is that word primarily the get out of
jail card could that be the reason the
pm can say no covert rules were broken
yeah he could possibly go down that uh
that route but uh i think he would be
then emphasizing there's one set of
rules in downing street uh
for for his gang and another set of
rules for the rest of the country
because many many people had christmas
parties uh cancelled i i had my work
christmas party cancelled you don't have
to get the violins out
it was just
yet another one that went so i think
he'd be in serious trouble if he tried
to pretend they were somehow exceptional
and play
play it down
um because the i pick up just like the
guardian that this is rushed and i think
you'd have to be
criminally gullible
to think the announcement would have
been tonight on plan b had the video not
been leaked of allegra stratton uh
joking and laughing about
how to cover up for a party because you
could see a year ago they were already
plotting the cover up and that's what
the whole point of the questions to get
her answers were how can you
hide what has happened and she's on a
lot of the front pages and she looks
very very very tearful um i know
uh when she was a journalist at the
guardian then she went to the bbc then
she went to itv then she popped over to
the treasury worked for um rishi sunak
then she was going to be the public face
and voice of johnson's government in
that 2.6 million
um media center
but like anybody who gets involved and
gets close to boris johnson you get
burned it always happens he just plows
on himself and there must be other
people in number 10 now
frightened he's going to be chucking
them under the the bus
as well and uh you know the metro front
the pm taking the public for fools
kierst starmer will be thrilled that his
line at um prime minister's questions
has been picked up on the metro and it's
striking accord with the population it's
not to say johnson of the conservatives
couldn't bounce back some way in the
future but at the moment the
listed all those uh mistakes his sleaze
the great train robbery um problems with
uh people crossing the channel is also
the
the social care uh i would say a con
because some people will still have to
sell their homes and labor's branded
working-class dementia attacks he's lost
the magic he's lost he's lost the touch
but it's yeah it's the cover-up if when
the mirror had a broken story about the
party last week he'd say look we'll
investigate i'll i'll see and then he
probably would have to admit there was a
party and play it down he would have
taken some hits but he just built up and
up and up because of the ludicrous
denials some people just were misled and
then misled the public others lied and
it's come back and bitten them really
really big time he's turned what was uh
a problem in a huge crisis which is now
engulfing him and it's going to be very
very difficult for him to to shake off
and as he throws more people under the
bus it's going to happen in downing
street there are going to be more people
who will leak against him and speak out
against them because they will see
they've just been used and abused okay
uh we will talk more about this after
the break there's so much to discuss uh
including those uh messages about
working from home are they mixed uh
christmas parties too we will discuss
that in just
[Music]
welcome back to watching the press
preview with me now kevin maguire and
ali mirage welcome back to both of you
uh we talked earlier about whether plan
b was rushed out as a diversion who
knows but the daily telegraph is
certainly pointing to holes in it
already as many have uh the headline
says it all don't go to work but do go
to parties uh that'll work then kevin
yeah so i can go to my uh work christmas
party but i can't go to my workplace to
work uh
the contradictions are really glaring
for instance you got to wear a mask well
you've got to show proof to get in uh
jab proof or a negative test to get into
a night club but not a really crowded
pub
you have to uh
[Laughter]
you but you see those uh there are
contradictions that
if you could explain them by showing the
impact of each action and how many cases
of covert it would prevent then i think
you could justify it but just making the
announcements without giving the data i
think is again going to undermine public
compliance
well the sun uh new kerbs as pm reels
over party do as i say not as i
christmas do
uh
you know all over the front page you can
do as you please till you get found out
i mean it goes on and on doesn't it
do do you hope this isn't long-term
damaging uh ali do you think for the
prime minister himself you know that he
has been holed under the water
effectively
well i'm afraid it's too early to tell
anna whether it's long-term damaging or
not i mean until now
the prime minister's get out of jail
cold on the back of dominant comings in
that fiasco last year and various other
mishaps has been that
um
the labour party has been patently
unelectable now we know that uh
governments lose elections rather than
oppositions within them although
oppositions need to look credible and
certainly kierstarm has been trying to
make efforts in recent weeks to try and
make his front bench uh look more
credible and the one thing kierstama's
got going for him is he's not jeremy
corbyn so i think that the tories need
to be careful about this and put this
complacency aside there's a comres poll
out
over the last day or so
saying that 66 percent of the british
public want the prime minister to
apologize for this supposed christmas
party that happened last year with 50
just under 50 of tory voters also
wanting him to do the same and i i was
talking to various backbenchers over the
last 24 hours who feel
that they've been trotted out one of
them cited uh jeffrey
uh saying when when uh he uh dug the
knife into margaret thatcher
it's rather like they've been they've
been sent out to to to go to the crease
when they're the team captain's broken
their bats before the first balls have
been bolted okay ali kevin thank you
both very much indeed thank you